في عواجل وردت قبل حوالي ع دقائق وحتى
الان الجيش الاسرائيلي يعلن مقتل ضابطين
في معارك في شمال قطاع غزه ما يرفع عدد
جنوده القتلى اليوم الى سبعه والجيش
الاسرائيلي ايضا يقول بارتفاع عدد الضباط
والجنود القتلى الى
84 منذ بدء العمليه البريه والى
408 منذ هجوم السابع من اكتوبر ايضا كتائب
القسام اعلنت ان مقاتليها خاضوا منذ صباح
هذا اليوم اشتباكات عنيفه مع قوات
الاحتلال في جميع محاور التوغل في قطاع
غزه وقالت القسام انها احصت تدمير 24 اليه
عسكريه كليا او جزئيا فقط في محاور القتال
بمدينه خانيونس واضافت ان مقاتليها
استهدفوا 18 جنديا بالهجوم المباشر كما
اوقع قناصه القسام ثمانيه جنود بين قتيل
وجريح واعلنت كذلك عن تفخيخ ونسف منزل
تحصن فيه عدد من جنود الاحتلال مما ادى
الى انهيار المبنى تماما في محور شرق
خانيونس
اضافت القسام ان مقاوميها فجروا حقل الغام
في عدد من جنود الاحتلال واوقع بين قتيل
وجريح في المحور
نفسه كما اعلنت ان مقاوميها وجهوا رشاقات
صاروخيه مكثفه نحو واهداف متنوعه
وبمد مختلفه الى الاراضي المحتله